foreign
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar Beyond metabolism expanding the
horizons of pharmacogenomic testing with
NGS
I am Michelle Ashton of Labor roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Thermo Fisher Scientific
to learn more visit thermalfisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker
Jonathan Stein CSO medical director
thesis biosciences Jonathan you may now
begin your presentation
thanks Michelle and thanks everybody for
listening into this webinar
so uh my name is Dr Jonathan Stein and I
am the chief science officer and medical
director for thesis biosciences and
today I'm delighted to talk to you about
um
uh pharmacogenomic testing what it is
how it works and sort of where it's all
going and why it's important so let me
Jump Right In first let me give you uh
my back story and this is sort of my
little um disclaimer slide
so this is my background I guess it's
also my conflict of interest I like all
these guys this is these are the places
I've worked I'm basically a small town
molecular geneticist um from a place
called Los Angeles maybe you've heard of
it uh and I have done a lot of r d and a
lot of molecular genetics in my day
um
thesis biosciences is a Cancer and
molecular Diagnostics laboratory
Consortium based in Colorado Texas and
um
Arizona
and we do a lot of testing uh and what
I'm going to talk to you about today is
again uh the role that pharmacogenetics
plays in diagnostic testing and it's
kind of utility and sort of future
applications I should also thank Thermo
Fisher for hosting this uh webinar
presentation which is absolutely lovely
we use some of their stuff for some of
our stuff and it works pretty great for
us and that's pretty much the only thing
you're going to hear from me on that
topic today
so uh let me start by saying that
um
when people originally looked at the
interaction of genes and diseases the
historical estimates for them was
thought to be kind of eight to twenty
percent on the high end you know more
for some diseases less for others
um but recent Studies have shown this is
a huge population study using uh U.S
insurance database data where they took
relatedness information from about 56
000 Twins and one of zygotic or
dizygotic
um you know identical or sibling Twins
and 70 to 724 000 sibling pairs living
together in separate zip codes to look
at environmental effects they found that
the heritability for genetic involvement
in diseases runs on average about 40
percent again it's different for
different diseases
uh but where I was going with this is
that
um genes play a much larger role in
disease processes than previously
thought and that means that getting
genetic information is that much more
important in terms of uh making clinical
decisions making clinical diagnoses
so this is the know your audience
question I know not everybody here is a
molecular biologist so I just want to
briefly to say that there are many types
of genetic variations but we are mostly
discussing uh single nucleotide
polymorphisms which are sometimes called
Snips they're single base pair changes
a lot of times they uh they don't have
any clinical relevance but in some cases
in some genes and some sequences
a change in a single set of base pairs
will result in a change in the shape of
the protein that the that the DNA is the
blueprint for
and because of that it may impact
protein function and the protein
function we're interested in is the
ability of your body or these particular
proteins that have a role in
metabolizing
um medications that is say they're
breaking down drugs
um so your body can excrete them or
activating them so your body can use
them and both of those things are very
important
in terms of terminology and
you'll see a couple different ones used
there's pharmacogenomics which is uh the
study of how variations in the human
genome dictate a person's response to
medications
um and again the purpose of this kind of
testing to determine the risk of side
effects or the likelihood of
effectiveness of a given medication
pharmacogenetics refer typically refers
to a limited number of genes often
involving drug metabolism and
pharmacogenomics sort of this bigger
study of how complex multi-gene patterns
work within the genome I'll argue later
on that there these are just going to
merge we're just going to get a lot a
lot a lot more genetic information and
so it'll be a more of a whole genome um
study
um you'll often hear them used
interchangeably though really
um there's also Precision medicine which
is form of medicine that uses
information about a person's own genes
or proteins to prevent diagnose or treat
disease
um this is also sometimes called
personalized medicine or Precision
Health it is really well implemented in
cancer
uh in cancer treatment at this point
where uh information about a sequence a
person's tumor and this will help to
make a diagnosis plant treatment find
how well the treatment is working or
make a prognosis you know to see what
the predicted outcome is of the disease
I also want to briefly discuss
therapeutic failures and adverse drug
reactions because they are going to play
a really important role in
uh the relative value of pharmacogenetic
testing
so ADR is adverse drug reactions right
negative side effects or adverse effects
from treatment how common are they well
in one large study
um back in the day they looked at uh 3
700 hospitalized patients in Britain and
about 14.7 percent experienced one or
more adverse drug reactions with each
additional medication increasing the
likelihood of an episode by about 14
percent
uh ADR is direct to increase the length
of stay in about a quarter of patients
that experienced it and the drugs most
frequently associated with them include
diuretics opioids anticoagulants
in the U.S about 2 million people suffer
the manually accounts for about seven
percent of all Hospital admissions uh
serious drug toxicities cause over 4.5
million emergency room visits per year
and a hundred thousand deaths annually
with costs estimated to be 30 to 100
billion dollars a year
uh risks of ADR susceptibility it's not
just genetic they include someone's
immune system again their genetics their
demographics age and gender uh
physiological and exogenous factors such
as drug drug interactions and diseases
and disorders such as renal failure or
liver failure which might impact their
ability a person's ability to process
drugs
contrary wise large numbers of Studies
have looked at the health care savings
from implementing PGX and they range
from about
um so if you do pharmacogenomic testing
on people before you give the medication
the savings range from three to ten
thousand dollars per patient per year
and I'll I'll go into a little bit more
detail about that part uh later but I
guess where I'm going with this is uh
this is common this problem is a very
common problem
therapeutic failure
uh is when a medication doesn't work and
it is a huge problem in psychiatric
pharmacology with about 40 percent of
patients non-responsive to any
particular antidepressant medication 20
of patients non-responsive to any
particular antipsychotic drug
and uh though there is relatively little
um
information about this uh issue in terms
of birth control we know I have six
aunts and boy did they give me an earful
when I asked them about this but the
average woman tries three methods of
contraception by age 40 and by uh 30 try
five or more methods by that age uh
because of side effects because they do
not like how they feel on these
medications contraceptive failure rates
run one to ten percent when they look at
normal versus perfect use so I just put
five percent up here and so this is also
another area where there is a lot of
opportunity for improvement
uh sort of canonical example of uh
therapeutic failure by the by is um
oh gosh women who get pregnant on birth
control
so
so here's a very brief overview of PGX
basically it's specific to the
medication it's specific to the patient
right it's individualized medicine and
basically for any given medication
someone gets binned as either uh fast a
fast uh slow or sort of an average
metabolizer you'll see the nomenclature
bounces around where sometimes
intermediate gets used as someone who is
um a slightly sore metabolizer you also
hear Ultra fast and Ultra slow
metabolizers
um and again these vary by drug and
interaction pathway and there's websites
like clingen and Univar uh where the
sort of clinical applications and
clinical utility for any given Gene can
be identified I come at this as a
geneticist so
um that's sort of where we you know go
to look at a sort of research
aggregations to see what's going on
so there's a couple different ways to do
this technology we use NGS
NGS has a ton of applications you can
use it for whole genome sequencing or
whole exome sequencing or targeted panel
sequencing as you can see up here we
kind of focus
um because only a limited number of
genes are currently identified uh as
being clinically relevant in terms of
PGX testing we'll typically do targeted
panel sequencing
so there are many applications for NGS
hereditary disease detection or risk
modification for common diseases
detection and treatment strategies for
circulating tumor DNA people can also do
very early detection of birth defects
through circulating fetal DNA detection
of common pathogens in fluids you know
which sequence whatever is in the fluid
and see what kind of bugs are in there
and also
pharmacogenetics treating for dosage and
treatment optimization
so the application we use here is to
um
is to do is to screen these kind of
discrete panels for genes that are known
to interact with medication
um again the risk varies across a number
of different demographic factors but the
reality is we're going to check in each
individual patient what's going on with
them
for some people for example you can see
the like uh you steps this like large
population of people kind of in the
center of this picture and they all get
the same diagnosis and the current
methodology is they get the same
prescription but for some of those
people see the sort of green one in the
upper left corner of that picture the
drug is going to be toxic but they may
still get an effect from it and in some
cases you have a yellow group the drug
isn't toxic but it's not going to help
them at all and in some cases the drug
will be toxic but not beneficial or not
toxic and not beneficial like every
possible combination and the goal of
this PGX testing is for any given
medication to identify where you or
where the patient is so that they can
get the correct medication
the key point on this slide is that
bottom sentence there 15 to 25 percent
of patients have a clinically relevant
variant for any given drug this is
common super common and if you've got
somebody on five drugs
you know it's a really good that one of
them
is that a contraindicated or at an
incorrected dosage based on their
particular genetics
so again you've got these you've got
these various bins that people go into
and and the nomenclature varies a little
bit so here they use extensive or what
are called normal drug metabolizers and
so there are these things called wild
type or normal alleles people try not to
use normal to stigmatize people who have
variant alleles but you know again your
wild type is sort of reversed to like an
average uh genotype and so these folks
are going to have a normal metabolism
and they won't need any dose
modification and this drug is fine for
them
and then um and this is 75 to 85 percent
of people again it varies uh for each
drug it varies by country of origin
patient population and gender those
sorts of issues
um
then you'll have other people who fall
into a group of intermediate
metabolizers and that might be 10 to 15
of people and so they might have one
variant copy they might have one wild
type or normal wheel one variant copy of
the wheel and so they may require a
lower than average dose for optimal
therapeutic response and then you might
have people who are poor metabolizers uh
where for any given gene they only have
the variant alleles yeah mutated delete
or a deletion in that allele so in those
cases they will tend to accumulate the
drug because they don't process it very
quickly and so for them they might
internally be experiencing a much higher
dose than say a normal metabolizer
they break down the drug much more
slowly and so it's accumulating in them
right so that might be getting 20
percent more or a hundred percent more
or even more than that and then on the
other end you've got people who are
Ultra rapid metabolizers where they
might have an amplification of the genes
of Interest or just have a very high
functioning variant and in those cases
the drug will fail because they will
break it down before it achieves a a
dosage level where it has a
physiological response
so for them it doesn't work at all and
again a couple of canonical examples
um there is a case where this is one of
the first examples that um brought
pharmacogenetics to sort of the
Forefront there was a case where a woman
got a C-section and she was taking uh I
believe codeine for pain management and
uh she was breastfeeding she was an
ultra slow metabolizer and so was her
baby and uh the intermediate breakdown
product of codeine is morphine and so
morphine was accumulating in her system
and because she broke it down very
slowly and it got into her
um into her mother's milk and the baby
suffered from an opiate overdose and so
uh you know what was discovered was
again both of them were very slow drug
metabolizers
um and so that's an example of that and
again the canonical example of an ultra
rapid metabolizer is you know someone
who takes antidepressant or they take a
a birth control and they break it down
much more quickly than uh than is
required for it to be physiologically
useful and so you have this um failure
for the medication
so um here I just um pulled the the
information from the FDA uh drugs uh
how many drugs are
um known in pharmacogenomics versus
therapeutic area and so you can see that
there are a vast minimum of drugs and
oncology down at the bottom uh followed
by psychology neurology infectious
diseases anesthesiology Cardiology and
so forth
um so this is sort of medications versus
therapeutic area but this uh this slide
doesn't really factor in the frequency
by which these drugs are prescribed
uh as sort of a general rule of thumb
about 80 of the most common medications
that are prescribed in this country in
the U.S
um are impacted by the patient's uh
genetics by their underlying genotypes
so you know for example even though
there's relatively few drugs it listed
in cardiology uh there are statins and
Warfarin and some of the most commonly
diagnosed drugs
um most commonly diagnosed medications
uh used in that field
so it's a little
um so while they're you know again many
drugs used in cancer the frequency this
isn't this isn't mapped by frequency
also there's just one contraceptive Yaz
or uh drospirinone uh on that list and
so I think again there's a huge
opportunity to make improvements uh in
the in this research space
so this is just
um FDA section one pharmacogenetic
associations for which the data supports
therapeutic management recommendations
and here you can see
um there's 13 genes that have made this
list uh there are numerous drugs uh that
are uh that are listed for each gene
and the takeaway here is that the
potential side effects are specific to
the mechanism of action of both the drug
and the genetic variant I'll talk a
little bit more about bche it's an
anesthetic
um and and sort of how this works out in
a little bit and there are many many
many more genes that Impact Drug
response that been identified at a
research level
um but uh optimizing dosage based on
genotype is actually a pretty high uh uh
clinical research evidence hurdled
across so there's actually relatively
few genes that are listed many many
drugs though
uh I just wanted to briefly show here
some of the models of PGX action so up
here you've got this drug uh sorry
you've got uh cyp 2d6 which I'll talk
about in a little bit it's used again
it's used in a lot of um it impacts it
is a gene that impacts many many
different uh drugs
um
so here we're looking at coding dosage
versus coding dosage versus Gene
functions or how that interacts so
here's an example where someone might
have uh increased function there might
be a high uh there might be a rapid
metabolizer and so for them to get any
effect from coding dosage they'd want to
higher morphine concentration
uh if they had normal uh normal cyp2d6
function then normal function would be
fine and a normal dosage would be just
fine if they had reduced function then
uh they would need a lower morphine
concentration again to get the same uh
the same pain relief effect and if they
had a lower no function then morphine
would be a terrible idea for them
right and again you can find this out on
the front end before they take the
medication by doing the genetic testing
rather than waiting um on the back end
to see what happens
right here is a drug called TPMT which
is
uh
uh sorry the genius TPMT the drug is six
mercaptopurine it is used for uh
transplant rejection uh but it has a
risk of hematological toxicity so if
somebody has reduced uh if the gene TPMT
has decreased function their increased
risk of hematological toxicity become
increases to until it's very high and so
again you can do front-end screening and
identify people who are good candidates
for this drug and who are bad candidates
for this drug and provide that
information on the front end
uh the picture over here uh is just
about a gene called sorry
um it is about a anti-leukemia drug
called Methotrexate and how it works in
What's called the MTHFR pathway and HFR
is another Gene that is involved in
pharmacogenetic regulation because that
pathway this this thing called the MTHFR
cycle down here is what gets inhibited
by Methotrexate and if somebody has a
reduced MTHFR function that pathway
moves really slowly and so Methotrexate
will accumulate and this is from the
slide is from a study on adverse effects
of Methotrexate on pediatric leukemia
patients so you've got kids and you want
to reduce the amount of nausea and
headaches and muscle aches
um and vomiting from them and knowing
these kids genotype
knowing what the statuses of their
mthfr's ability to uh
to function gives information about
appropriate dosing of Methotrexate so
that they can have a better time of that
particular anti-cancer treatment
so here is uh section two FDA also used
section three in a second pharmaco
associations first the data indicates a
potential impact on safety or response
so here they just know
whether there's a high risk of adverse
reaction or not they're 10 genes they're
mostly the same ones from panel a but
with additional drug effects that have
been identified so here I'll just walk
you through it there's this drug called
uh efavorens and it's an HIV antiviral
and if somebody has the poor
metabolizing genotype for the gene
cyp2b6 then
um then they have a much higher uh
systemic concentration right so it
floats around their system longer and so
they have higher risk of an adverse
reaction right an adverse drug response
so that's how that works
so this slide just shows FDA section
three the potential impact on
pharmacokinetic properties only so this
just speaks to if somebody is a Ultra
fast metabolizer or a slow metabolizer
maybe they're going to want higher or
lower dosage recommendations and and we
you know as a laboratory we just sort of
provide that information right where
where it's known
so these six genes you'll also see them
in the other lists
um you know there's only a handful of
genes uh total that are um that are uh
kind of listed for FDA but again they
cover about 80 of the drugs that are
prescribed
so uh just a quick walk through uh
cholesterol is a muscle relaxant and if
someone has variants in cyp two c19 here
they might be a poor metabolizer and so
this will result in higher systemic
concentrations and so for these folks
they might benefit
from a lower dosage
um our PGX panel covers kind of all the
genes that are listed in FDA sections
one two and three so we we tend to go
with the highest level of evidence the
highest level of approval
well while hoping that more of them get
added to that list
I also wanted to talk a little bit about
you know again in the future this is
just absolutely going to explode in
utility and complexity over the next few
years has more genetic information
becomes available
I wanted to shift gears a little bit and
talk about
um kind of how this some real world
applications to this and some of the
other panels we offer so here are I'm
going to discuss briefly genes
associated with anesthesia response
there's an ldt we offer
uh adverse anesthesia response impacts
about one to two percent of patients so
it's less common than uh than uh the
total adverse drug responses but it can
be quite severe
of which kind of the best uh the best
characterized is called malignant
hyperthermia so this is a situation in
which someone gets exposed to an
anesthetic they have a severe reaction
and they essentially start to cook
internally they rapidly increased with
dangerously high body temperature their
muscle cells can start uh breaking down
they have rigid muscles or spasms
accelerating heart rate and other
symptoms and without prompt treatment uh
complications can be fatal
so you know essentially they start
having a massive heat stroke and again
it impacts depending on population and
and other things about two percent of
all patients who undergo anesthesia is
common
uh bche uh which I think was the top of
the table one in the FDA because
it's very very early identified
um
so Cino choline is a drug that's used
for facilitating tracheal incube
intubation in emergencies or for
patients with a high risk of vomiting
basically it temporarily paralyzes uh
the throat and the respiratory muscles
so that they can get the tube in uh some
people are and it does it fairly quickly
they go under very you know it paralyzes
them very briefly they get the tube in
and they breathe normally but some
people are slow metabolizers and so they
are at risk of asphyxiation because of
prolonged incapacitation of the
respiratory muscles when they get a
normal average dose of Cessna choline
and again it's incredibly useful to know
in advance what that response is going
to look like and what the optimized
dosage is going to be for them
so it was one of the first
pharmacogenetic disorders identified and
the other thing to say is that there are
over 60 Snips in bche that have been
reported so some of which have
functional impact some of which that
don't and so a sort of a small panel
isn't going to capture that for these
guys you're better off just sequencing
the entire Gene and catching any risk
markers that are out there
there are other malignant hypothermia
anesthesia responsive genes uh CAC and
a1s which is in our panel it's a again a
susceptibility to hyperthermia Gene
they're both calcium channel channel
encoding genes and so
um I guess the mechanism of action is
that the medication kind of uncouples
these channels and starts this kind of
chain reaction that starts the muscles
locking and spasming and then cooking
uh it's strongly actionable for a number
of different drugs
uh and again the variants are spread
throughout the entirety of the gene so
similar to breast cancer one uh the one
gene you're just better off sequencing
the whole thing to identify uh uh any
any any risk variants
so um you know one of the complexities
is that um
when you do a whole Gene sequencing so
R1 is is associated with hypothermia but
it's also associated with other
conditions here Ry R1 and the green box
is also associated associated with
malignant hyperthermia our way around
related myopathy so sort of muscle
diseases sarcopenia fatigue Myasthenia
Graces so you can gravis so you can end
up in a situation where the doctor or
patient gets more information they
expected as a function of testing in
terms of familial risk and in some cases
genetic counselors are just a critical
component of these sorts of
conversations
so going to looking at where this
testing is going
um here I think you can take a page from
cancer genetics where there you know
number of genes have been identified
that are associated with increased risk
of cancer but these genes are modified
by a wide variety of other
um
by a number of different other actors
there are Upstream signaling mechanisms
receptor variants that are relation
they're transcriptional Regulators their
translational Regulators the signals
that these provide like you know they
they send the message to Downstream
genes or Downstream proteins as part of
a complex signaling pathway and
modifications in any of these systems
can result in big differences in the
function of these cancer genes and
that's probably going to be the case as
well
um with genes involved in medications
so again there's lots of different ways
to turn up or down the function of Any
Given Gene and here we're just looking
like what we're currently doing is we're
just looking at genetic variants that
impact function within that single Gene
whereas we know that there are some
regulatory systems that can turn up or
down like a volume control or a light
dimmer switch uh the uh concentration of
these genes or their ability to get
turned into proteins and so forth
so here I just posted a couple different
uh slides looking at some of these
regulatory factors so cyp2d6 again very
important for drug metabolism and it has
known transcriptional activators
right
um retinoids induce the expression of
these regulatory elements pregnancy can
impact them and this can result in
reduced expression of some of these
transcriptional activators and so these
will modulate the amount of cyp2d6 so
you can imagine a situation where
someone has a normal they make a normal
cyp 2d6 Gene but they don't make very
much of it
right because one of these genes uh that
are Upstream of the activation of this
Gene uh one one of the activators it
doesn't function that well or one of the
repressors works super well
um so once you get sort of in the
regulatory weeds of these genes there's
a lot of different ways
that they can be that their activity can
be modified we know this from cancer and
so you know when we look at
pharmacogenetics we are going to
identify more of these over time there
are splice variants Within These genes
that have been identified what are the
impact of these on pharmacogenetics
don't know yet
right cypd6 is is strongly associated
with both drug metabolism and
schizophrenia so
um our uh variance in the expression
going to have effect are there are there
different uh genetic uh factors at play
here are the different
um splice forms of these genes going to
be relevant we will find out in the
years to come
maybe neurotransmitters are being
rapidly metabolized in the system we
just don't know
finally just again another example is a
pretty noisy slide but my only Point
here is that there's a world of
interacting regulatory factors for
pharmacogenetic Associated genes and
some of them are quite novel and quite
subtle here they're these things called
uh what is it micro interfering rnas uh
that bind to the RNA that gets produced
by these genes before they get made into
protein and down regulates them or
inhibits their ability to get turned
into proteins so that the amount of the
these genes
can be upregated or down regulated by
these other factors and again
um more you know since since I made this
slide more uh micro RNA Regulators have
been identified so so these are going to
play a role in how much of this protein
is around so you can imagine a situation
like where you are a uh a high you know
you have highly functioning uh cyp 2d6
proteins you're a high metabolizer but
you have
um a micro RNA inhibitor that is also
high functioning and so it prevents you
from making that much of
um this and so you're a normal you're in
in effect a normal metabolizer right
those sorts of questions and the ability
to ask those sort of questions and make
those sorts of clinical uh clinically
relevant calls or what's going to be
coming up in the years to come
100 percent
so very briefly I just wanted to say
there's been many studies to look at the
cost effectiveness of PGX testing I sort
of squinted at them and it looks like uh
for the average patient it saves getting
this testing done saves a couple Grand a
year uh for each year going forward that
they're testing the estimates range
about one to three thousand annually if
you sort of squint and look at the big
picture however uh in specific cases
there are enormous benefits to PGX
testing so it turns out getting someone
with suicidal ideation on the right
antidepressant quickly has enormous
benefits in terms of uh sort of the
economic measurement what's called
quality adjusted life year so in the
Canadian health system which is sort of
the second bullet
uh PGX assisted treatment for depression
cost Effectiveness range from 12 to 16
000 per quality adjusted life year right
um preventing someone from killing
themselves by getting them on the right
antidepressant quickly turns out is
enormously beneficial
um some uh some cardio some cardio drugs
have um have a small but significant
savings and some of them are huge
so I guess the fourth bullet down here
uh press the grill for anti-platement
therapy on a large number of patients
studied looking at uncontrolled bleeding
unguided treatment resulted in a cost of
about 40 000 pounds in this study and
this number was brought down to about 8
000 pounds when they did PGX first and
they removed the known high-risk people
from
um from that treatment or they went to
an alternative treatment the simple
economic analysis can be confounded
because in some cases you're taking
somebody off a cheap drug because
they're going to have adverse effects so
they're going on a more expensive drug
but they're having less adverse effects
so the health economics doesn't
necessarily capture the quality of life
improvements associated with making a
better PGX informed medication decisions
Arabs laboratory very briefly uh they uh
tested their own staff so they had 228
voluntary participants Arab Labs is a
fantastic diagnostic laboratory in Salt
Lake City and they found that um of
their staff about 54 of them were taking
medications that were going to have
adverse effects on them
so there were 54 uh percent of the
recommendations were to use a different
medication than the one they were on
again an average population they were
fine but no individual is average and
when you factor in someone's uh genetic
individuality and their biochemical
individuality
um there are lots of opportunities for
improvement
of those recommendations that were made
uh 41 were related to psychiatric
medications about a third related for
chronic pain getting those dosage
optimized and 13 for cardiovascular
drugs
um they were trying to do a long-term
study on the economic benefit but uh
they did the study during the year of
covid so it's kind of things kind of
went off the rails as I remember from
their presentation they were looking at
something like uh 10 annual improvements
in terms of
wait um
in terms of health care costs
doing it
might have been absenteeism
so again the sum right here is that a
preponderance of evidence suggest that
PGX treatment is cost effective and
often cost saving when considering
treatment with medications that have
known genetic interactions
um as is a parent in Psychiatry Pedic
testing is especially invaluable where
multiple medications with well
documentation with well-documented
associations are considered
there are challenges in terms of
implementing uh PGX you know there's a
sort of regulatory hurdle where there's
you know sort of research Galloping
ahead of of approval and
uh developing testing has its own
challenges sort of ldts versus
um uh versus kit based testing uh
there's challenges in terms of study
design that I think sort of got alluded
to in the previous slide
um you know you have to do PGX versus
each medication and you have to Define
your outcomes clearly there's
differences in study design and
inpatient populations
some new drugs you may not know which
metabolic pathways are involved and
there's obviously all sorts of an
emergency emergences there there are
many new clinically significant genetic
variants
um that again have sort of galloped
ahead of the sort of regulatory piece
here
um you know there's challenges in
clinical implementation you know for you
know you know for these custom testing
panels uh you have to you know there's
compliance in terms of ordering and
interpretation and billing there's
institutional uh inertia
um you know you have to make sure that
there's sufficient evidence and utility
and and again FDA approval and obviously
there's patient privacy concerns about
how this uh how these results are used
properly
um sort of for us uh we focus on a
couple of things you know obviously uh
our main focus is on clinical utility
and compliance
um you know does the test inform the
diagnosis or treatment we generate an
enormous amount of information through
this testing you know if you sequence a
whole person you get about four
terabytes of data
um
but the clinician doesn't only needs the
information that is actionable in terms
of diagnosis and prognosis and treatment
so we um you know while as a geneticists
we get to geek out on this information
it's super interesting stuff
um for the clinician and for the patient
they only need to know what is important
to them and so
um spending a lot of time on curation
making sure that the actionable
information is what gets to them so that
people in a hurry and do what they need
to do and get on with their lives
right there are many different working
groups
um you know uh and different consortiums
that compile this evidence and it's
changing all the time and so it's
important to stay current on that and
that's another thing that we um focus on
here
so this brings us to the um
opportunities and challenges of
personalized medicine right on a
prevention level you can detect patients
at risk at an early stage and improve
their preventative measures right if you
know you are higher high high risk
um for taking a medication for example
you can take something different if the
opportunity if the Alternatives exist
and that's again the sort of information
that that a good report can provide
uh
uh you can get accurate disease
diagnosis enabling individualized
treatment uh strategy specific to the to
the underlying Pathways involved and
then finally you can improve outcomes
through targeted treatment and reduce
diet effects so that's the payout of
moving towards a more personalized
medicine paradigm
finally again my I admit I'm a little
biased as a geneticist but since
Precision medicine saves money I think
it's only a matter of time and data
accumulation before this becomes
standard of care it's just too common
for someone to have a variant that is
going to impact their uh their treatment
outcomes right if you're trying to
reduce adverse drug responses if you're
trying to take effective doses you know
not get these little overdoses or not
get underdosed of a medication it's just
two these genetic variants that impact
that decision are just too common so
that's where I think this is going
um
uh in the slide uh from narens 2018 uh
they sort of say current reactive
Medical Care model I kind of think
that's a little heavy-handed I think
what we're currently doing is empirical
medicine you make the diagnosis you try
the therapeutic people come back you
find out if that worked you switch and
switch and switch is needed until you
get it right here in the personalized
medicine Paradigm you get screened on
the front end and then you know which
drugs to avoid or what what optimal
doses are going to look like and then
you can monitor from there so that's
where I think that's all going I think
there's going to be explosion and risk
and severity markers as a human gene
genome
testing becomes more ubiquitous and more
cost effective you know the prices have
gone down from billions to thousands to
about a thousand uh to lower than that
so I think we are going to have an
explosion of genetic information and
then the focus for us is going to be on
clinical utility you know getting
actionable information to patients and
clients and clinicians so that they can
make those better decisions and improve
their health care outcomes I put my
email up there if you have any questions
and I want to thank you all for
listening in and I hope you've enjoyed
this webinar
thank you Jonathan for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
all right let's go ahead and get started
our first question is where do you see
the future of pharmacogenomics going and
how does NGS fit into it
oh that's such a great question thank
you for asking it uh again I think
cancer is the best model for this so all
the known
um All the known uh cancer genes have
regulatory elements promoter variants uh
interfering RNA upstream and downstream
modeling functional modulating genes
that are going to likely impact uh that
you know that we know impact outcome and
my guess is that that's going to hold
true for pharmacogenomics as well again
I I think there's going to be eventually
we'll have a comprehensive sort of whole
genome NGS approach towards this
and we'll have identified many more
variants that maybe are rarer right
maybe they impact fewer people but for
those individuals it's incredibly
important and those will get sort of
added to the list over time
right and again the frequency of PGX
variants are such I think is going to be
standard of care and you know I wanted
to slam the FDA for doing slow to get
these tier one evidence genes approved
but you know of the sort of farm gkb the
sort of big database uh lists there's
about 873 drugs that are known to exist
uh that have annotations based on
genetic variants and the FDA lists about
half of them so I don't actually think
they're doing that badly on that front
but I mean again there's twice as many
drugs out there that sort of haven't
gone through this evidentiary process so
those are all coming you know those will
all come with time
um research tends to gallop faster than
um than safety and that and then sort of
FDA and that that sort of makes sense
you know the FDA associated with safety
and research is about finding stuff out
so I think in time uh one will catch up
with the other and we'll have a lot more
information
to give to people
okay great thank you your next question
what are the most important
considerations when choosing an NGS
platform for pharmacogenomics testing
uh that's a great question too I mean
there are you know there's so there's a
couple things going on here there's
clinical considerations like assay
flexibility and accuracy and
reproducibility and then there's also
the business considerations which also
access assay flexibility because
again as research uh identifies new
markers you want to be able to add them
very quickly to to your testing panel
right as new genes get identified or new
drugs get get pulled in you you need
these sort of you need the flexibility
to do that but yeah again you also want
your setup and your per sample run costs
uh to be relatively low and you're going
to need a high level of support because
these are you know these are pretty
complex to set up
turnaround time is important throughput
is important important Financial
flexibility in terms of leasing versus
buying and all those things need to be
balanced when platforms are considered
but those those are the big ones for me
all right your next question
where do you see the value of NGS as a
modality in this space above other
Technologies like PCR
oh okay
um so this is kind of a no-brainer
um some of these some of these genes
have you know specific hot pots Hot Spot
Snips and you can do PCR to individually
identify them but in many of the genes I
showed you know the bcag R1 the the
variance the genetic variants that
people have are spread across the entire
Gene right so in those cases NGS is
going to be way better in terms of
providing comprehensive coverage of risk
identification
and because these risk alleles are
dispersed through the entire Gene at a
low frequency you definitely need an NGS
platform to identify them right the
alternative is you're you know
amplifying hundreds and hundreds of
snips and that's going to change over uh
all the time and very rarely will one of
them show up as opposed to sequencing
the entire Gene and identifying the
variants that are present
all right thank you Jonathan we have
time for a couple more questions
um your next question for labs looking
to enter the pharmacogenomic space what
advice would you give them to help them
succeed
oh what a great question okay so when
when my current lab was getting started
when Jesus was just getting started we
definitely benefited from working with
outside experts to validate our systems
our assays and our reporting so
um Next Generation sequencing is a very
B2B collaborative Endeavor like you are
definitely going to want to uh have a
dedicated experts who really know how to
do it and also do not skimp on it
support uh a single hole genome can
require four terabytes bytes of
information storage and uh PGX runs will
fill up your platform storage quicker
than you can imagine so you need to plan
it accordingly in terms of on-site or
Cloud flexible storage right
again the actual running gets very
routine but the setup can be quite
challenging and you're just you're just
far better off of bringing in experts to
help that out
all right thank you and your last
question around pharmacogenomics what
lessons have you learned over the years
that you wish you knew sooner okay so so
I'll I'll do two so I used to joke that
um uh that they called it next
Generation sequencing to make folks of
us who used to do um you know silver
staining silver sting gels and Counting
nucleotides feel old but it's actually
become hugely simplified right again the
startup is really complicated but once
things are running the process truly
looks plug and play uh compared to
um compared to back in the day I I
compare it to using a toaster versus
building a toaster from scratch
so so you know so don't be daunted by
that just bring in expert
um that's just the way to go and also I
should say these systems they generate
mountains of genetic information
um but clinicians only need to know a
small fraction of it which is the parts
that are clinically actionable so
wherever possible bring in people who
know how to curate that data
um so you're not you know you're not
drowning clients in information that
just isn't relevant
um you know telling someone that they
have a genetic variant of Uncertain
significance does them absolutely no
favors right
um whereas telling them you know here
are the pathological variants and here's
uh what is typically done with them you
know providing that information that is
something people can use and it's all
about providing value to people
thank you Jonathan do you have any final
comments for our audience before we
close today
sure I say this all the time but we are
in a golden age uh of biomedical
Sciences we are going to again as the as
the costs of whole genome sequencing and
whole exome sequencing uh get lower and
lower we are going to generate so much
clinically actionable information that
helps people uh make better decisions
about uh their lives and improves the
opportunity for them to live longer and
healthier lives so it's a wonderful
thing to be part of and I just want to
thank everybody for your time today
well thank you again Jonathan for your
time today and your wonderful
presentation we would also like to thank
lab roots and our sponsor Thermo Fisher
Scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labords will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye